Missy Elliott was at the party the party
was amazing there was a guy standing on
the wall
that nobody knew he was in a green uh
tracksuit jacket guess who it was
it was Jay-Z
didn't nobody and I walked past like
what's up said a nice party yes
it's nice it's a nice party it's crazy
it's like this all the time it's crazy
it's crazy I can't believe that that was
one of your first films and your face to
face with Al Pacino too goddamn
turnovers
in one half and he's swearing at you
giving him full hair dryer your fight
with your fingernails what's your go-to
impression not much I've been working on
my truck it's a lot of great people lots
of good people let's kiss excuse me
excuse me fake reviews fake reviews fake
reviews all right cool
cookies everyone get the cookies
everyone
today everyone look underneath your
seats
and I actually hung out with Mike during
all those times I remember Mike was so
rich he had Lamborghini trucks and just
crazy he was he'd be in the in the club
the girls like you like BMWs
they'd be like yeah he just go buy a
bushel of BMW BMWs
let me tell you something if you could
play the blues baby you could do
anything man hey let's play the blues
but we're playing right we're playing
and we're doing the blues one and then
he goes into Thelonious Monk and so I'm
trying to mirror him on that and then I
hit a wrong note point and he said you
know what now why the hell would you do
that I said what because to his his ears
are so sensitive yes
what the [__] are you doing I said I'm
sorry I didn't I didn't know he said hey
let me tell you something at the note to
write underneath your fingers baby all
you got to do that's life life is
hitting her right notes they hit the
right note
oh
yeah
foreign
I wasn't going to get in the music
business because I was too funny and I
was doing a show called In Living Color
and I was doing this one character named
Wanda
hey for real though
hey oh it's so good to see y'all hey
[Applause]
word up this is mine so Urban ones we
always talk about it with certain things
that you would say in movies that became
like your your calling card you get your
[__] hands off me oh really every
every I'm a comment so every every time
you get your [__] head that's right
I I'll grab your hand and you play me
hey you get your [__] hands off me
all of a sudden on this your boy Cruise
man we get attacked by some crazy ass
seagulls who ate a lot a lot of Mexican
food nice they ate a lot of Mexican food
and just bombed everyone and one person
in particular is really pissed off and
that's Mike Tyson who's on oh man and
he's going off and he's yelling at this
I'm saying you know I like something
seagulls you know because I usually have
pigeons so I'm so upset you do this
because I'm so nice to birth I don't
have to snap their necks and pick the
nose and break it up viciously
at one point we were having too much fun
and I got a call from Oprah Winfrey
Jamie Foxx Jimmy you're blowing it Jimmy
fall Jimmy Fox so she took me to Quincy
Jones's house it's just like my place so
what was your name Ray Roberts I'm
Quincy Jones and Quincy was like Hey man
you're doing a great job with that Ray
Charles man people are really excited
about it but listen you got to
straighten up and fly right
you know we don't want you to blow this
I don't wanna grow up
I am a Toys R Us get it
allowed a million times
that I could play with me
you know that that
off that that car hey you you not
because I don't like how it's how it
looks don't uh you know listen this
ain't even a hold on fam because
look but then I watched the pill
and then I'm okay yeah because
Chappelle's like you know yeah I was in
pants bam
can't talk about nothing mate
somebody walked up and they said there's
Dave Chappelle I said bam Wu-Tang I love
Dave because he always used a very
intelligent word to go with his hood I
was beside myself
I was chartreuse
bam
first day of rehearsal I'm reading my
lines like yeah
and he said cut can I talk you for a
second close the door
what the [__] is that what you mean I
knew I was going to have this problem uh
listen all of this [__] you have to be a
[__] slave okay he's a slave he's not
cool
he's a [__] slave right he doesn't
know how to read you come in with your
[__] Louie bag and your [__] Range
Rover
and your [__] Jess or I'm so [__]
you're not Jim Brown
he's a [__] slave and then and then
he becomes the hero but lose that [__]
door swings open he walks out wow would
you work with Quentin Tarantino again or
is it just two guys a thousand times
this
[Music]
when our president-elect said to the
American people and he said it very
smooth and calmly he said if there's
anyone who still doubts
that America is not a place where all
things are possible tonight is your
answer
Mike Tyson
Mike Tyson had
it was almost like
without cheapening what it was when I
would watch Daffy Duck or these animated
characters
[Music]
Daffy Duck had a lisp right so Mike
Tyson had that you know Mike it's a Mike
Tyson with boxing champion so and then
it was a matter of listening to them and
so then then it was Mike Tyson this
might have first of all you don't if I
can't wait back that's when he's young
yeah but now when I call Mike now
older everything all of the life that
he's lived the ups and the downs I call
Mike how you doing Mike I'll pray this
to Allah my brother I'm just happy why
because I don't have any money anymore
so I get nobody can take anything from
me because I did no more vultures no
more creatures around me I'm just happy
how are you my good brother so
it's matching the tongue and then
grabbing the mannerism